Hi, I'm Jamie.
And I'm going to
talk about developing
internal tools for
multilingual teams,
specifically teams
that use Python and R.
To get started,
I want to talk about pizza.
Imagine you having a couple
of friends over for dinner
and you need to
prepare them something.
The easiest thing to do is to
prepare them the same meal.
However, they're both
pretty fussy eaters.
Do you make two
entirely different meals
with all the extra ingredients,
prep time and aggravation?
No, you make pizza
because even if you
make a margherita
pizza for one friend
and a Hawaiian for
the other, they still
have the same base, the
same core ingredients.
What does pizza have
to do with R and Python?
The prospect of developing
a tool in both R and Python
can feel like you're
about to prepare
two entirely different meals.
It's twice the effort,
twice the cognitive load
and can take a lot more time.
How can we take the
principle of our pizza party,
that is making two different
meals with the same base,
and apply it to developing
bilingual tools?
This is a question I think
about a lot in my job.
So I work at Bumble.
We are the company behind the
dating and social networking
apps, Badoo, Bumble and Fruitz.
My job is to develop internal
packages for our data analysts.
Now most of our
analysts work in Python.
However, some of our
projects are done in R.
This means some of
our internal packages
are developed in both languages.
But why do we need
internal packages?
Well, internal packages can
help to automate and standardize
procedures that are specific
to your organization.
For example, an internal
package might automatically
apply company
styling to a report
or enable a user to connect
to an internal database
in the correct way.
To borrow from
Emily Riederer's
RStudio global talk,
internal packages are
kind of like members
of your organization
with specific jobs
to do. But why develop in
both Python and R?
The answer is simple.
In a multilingual
organization, we
want everyone to follow the
same internal procedures,
regardless of the language
that they're using.
The question I will
try to address today
is, what strategies
can we use to make
developing tools simultaneously
with Python and R easier?
In truth, this is
a very big topic
with lots of branching ideas.
Therefore, today I will focus
on three ideas that have helped
me to develop bilingual tools.
The first idea I
want to talk about
is building identical
generic functions.
What is a generic function?
Let's look at this
from the R perspective.
Generic functions are very
common in the R language.
For example, functions like
print or summary or tidy
from the broom package.
The really cool
thing about generics
is that they behave
in different ways
depending on the class of an
object that is passed to them.
Under the hood, this is
achieved using a process called
method dispatch.
As an internal
developer, you might
want to build a package that
uses custom internal classes,
and you may want
your users to be
able to call methods like
print or summary on them.
In some cases,
you may even want
to define your own
generic functions.
Let's take a look at
what generic functions
look like in code.
To do this, we'll
create a new package
which will provide one
function, say hello,
and this will print a nice,
friendly greeting to an object
that we pass to it.
To start, we define
our generic function,
say hello, and in
the function body
we make a call to use
method passing it.
The name of our
generic as a string.
And that's it.
That's our generic.
But now we need a class
specific implementation
of this function.
And to do this, let, let's
make one for a dataframe.
And to do it we will
use dot notation,
say hello dot dataframe.
And in this new
function we print
a nice, friendly greeting.
And now if you want to catch
all implementation, say hello.
We will use the
default sudo class,
say hello dot default.
OK now we know how
our R package is going to work.
We need a Python version.
Can we write our Python version
in the same way as our R vision?
And the answer is Yes.
To do this, we're going
to import single dispatch
from the functools module.
And unlike in R,
we actually start
by defining our fallback
method for say hello.
And we decorate it
with single dispatch.
Now, if you're not
familiar with decorators,
think of them as wrapper
functions that change
the behavior of a function.
And now we're going
to create a dataframe
implementation of say hello.
In Python using a dataframe
object from the pandas library.
And we do this with
the register function.
And here I am passing that
dataframe to the register
function. And there we have it.
But what have we
actually achieved here?
Well, we have two different
tools, one in R one in Python,
that have the same
foundation, a say hello
generic with a data
frame implementation.
So both of my packages
work the same
conceptually. This is
good for end users.
They get a similar API to
work with regardless of
whether they're using
R or Python.
But also my code is
physically quite similar.
So when I go and make a
change in the Python version
of my code, I know
where to go and make
that change in the R
version of my code.
So building identical
generic functions
is going to save me a
lot of time and effort.
The next idea I will talk
about is identical error
handling with classes.
Let's look at this from
the Python perspective.
Now, if you're a
Python user, you're
probably familiar with
these kinds of exceptions,
file not found error, zero
division error, and key error.
Exceptions in Python
are themselves
classes that inherit from
other exception classes,
and you can probably
already tell
that the names of
these exceptions
are quite descriptive.
They form part of
the error message.
Now, as an internal
developer, you
can create your own
custom internal errors.
You can give them really
descriptive names,
and the error messages
that they give
can be as well
specific as you want,
even telling the user where to
go for help if that error has
been thrown.
The powerful thing about
exceptions in Python
is that they can be handled
explicitly, for example,
with an except statement.
I asked Python to
try running some code
and in the event of a
specific error, in this case
a file not found
error, I can run
an alternative block of code.
This gives me maximum
control over how
my code handles failure.
So we're building
a Python package
and we are handling
errors in this way.
But can we handle errors in
the same way in our R packages?
The answer is yes, but let's
look at some basic error
handling in R first.
If you're an R
user, you may have
seen one of these two functions,
stop from base R, and abort
from the rlang package.
Both functions signal
an error and in R,
if we want to handle
errors in our code,
we can use something like
a try catch function.
But notice here on
the second line,
the error handler is a function
that will execute in response
to any error.
It's not designed to
handle a specific error,
and this is a problem.
I now have a lot less
control over my code
and more importantly, my
Python and R packages
handle failure in
very different ways.
How can we overcome this?
Well, the answer to this is
within the abort function
from rlang.
Let me illustrate
this with an example.
I'm going to create a new
function, abort credentials
missing.
And within the call
to rlang abort,
I am going to give a
specific class name. Here,
It's error credentials missing.
Now the really great thing
about error functions in R
is that you can create an
equivalent Python exception.
So as an internal developer,
you have your Python exceptions
and you have your
R error functions.
They're one and the same.
So when you make a
change in one language,
you know where to make that
change in the other language.
But what have we gained by
giving our error a class name?
Well, let's go back
to try catch.
You can see here
on the second line,
I can now write a specific
error handler for my new error,
error credentials missing and now
my Python package and my R package
handle failure in the same way.
I want to round off
this section on errors
by talking about error chaining.
In essence, error chaining is
throwing an error in response
to another error.
One use for this is
to give a high level
context to a lower level error.
Doing this in
Python is very easy.
For example, you can give your
original error an alias. Here
I'm giving it the
alias E. And then
I'm raising another exception
from that original exception.
And this gives me a kind
of double error message.
I get my original error
and then Python tells me
that this error caused
another error.
Can we emulate this in R?
The answer is yes.
Now, the way that we're going
to do this is we're going to use
try fetch from the rlang
package instead of a try catch.
And in my error handler, I'm
going to pass my condition
object to the abort
function, specifically
the parent argument.
And here I get a kind
of double error message.
And then we have it.
Our Python and R packages
now conduct error chaining
in the same way.
The third idea I
want to talk about
is creating your own
internal wrappers.
But what is an
internal wrapper?
Well, it's a package
written in one language that
wraps functionality
from another language.
But why would you want to create
your own internal wrapper?
Well, imagine a scenario
where a piece of functionality
is available in one
language, but not the other.
A well known example
is a statistical model
that's released as an R package,
but not a Python package.
But you want all
of your analysts
to be able to access
that functionality.
Another scenario
you might encounter
is that both languages have
their own implementation
of a piece of functionality,
like a statistical model.
But maybe the
underlying computations
aren't quite the same.
And therefore your analysts
get different results.
OK let's kick this
section off by looking
at how we call Python from R.
There are many ways to do this.
My method of choice is
the reticulate package.
Reticulate gives you a
number of different ways
to call Python code
in your R package.
Let's look at a
couple of examples.
Now, the first example is
importing Python modules
into R. This works really well
if the Python code
you're trying to access
is contained within
a Python package.
And to do this, I use the
import function from reticulate.
I give it the name
of my module, here
I call it py module, and
I assign it to a variable.
And now I can access functions
from that module using
this dollar sign notation.
Now, a really good
tip for when you're
doing this in an R package
is to create a global reference
to your Python package
and then you can use it
throughout your code.
Notice here, I'm not actually
importing anything yet.
I'm going to specify
how my Python module is
imported in on load function.
This will execute when
my R library is loaded.
And here, I'm specifying
the delay load to true.
And what this does is it
gives my end user the ability
to specify their own custom
Python virtual environment
to use with my package.
Another way that you can use
Python code in your R package
is to source Python files.
This might work well if the
code you're trying to access
is contained within
a Python script.
To do this, I'm going to
use a Python file. Here,
it's called add dot py, which
is contained in my R package
and inside that file I define
a new function, add two. And now
I will use source Python
from the reticulate package,
and then I can access
the add two function.
OK, we've called Python from R.
Now let's call R from Python.
Again there are many
ways to do this.
My method of choice is
the rpy2 package.
rpy2 gives you a
number of different ways
to call R code from
your Python package.
Let's look at some examples.
The first method is to import
R libraries into Python.
To do this, we're going
to import the import
R function from rpy2.
And then in this
example, we're actually
going to import
base R itself, which
we can import like
any other library.
To access a function
from base R,
we use this notation. Here, I
am accessing the sum function.
Now to use this
function, I'm going
to have to do a
little bit of work.
Sometimes when you're
using rpy2,
you need to convert objects
between R and Python.
In this example, I need
to convert my Python list
into an R vector.
I can do that using the int
vector function from rpy2.
You can check out the rpy2
documentation for more tips
on object conversion.
Another way to access R
code from Python using rpy2
is to create new
functions and access them
from the R environment.
This approach works
really well when
you have multiple
computation steps that
need to happen in
R. Now to do this,
we're going to first
import the R objects
module from rpy2.
We're then going to define
our R code as a string.
Here I'm just creating a new
function that returns one.
I then execute that
R code using the R
function from R objects.
And then I can access that
new function using global env
and assign it to a variable.
And now Python is actually a
function that I can execute.
Now a really great
utility that rpy2
gives you is the ability to
define a temporary package
structure.
And we can do this by
importing the STAP function
from rpy2.
And just like before, we
store our R code as a string,
and then we use STAP
to execute that code
and then we can access functions
from that code using this dot
notation.
So this approach
works really well
when you are
concerned about issues
like namespace conflicts.
OK now for the bad news.
Cross-language wrappers have
their own technical quirks
and headaches.
For example, you
have twice the number
of environments to think about.
Your users will need to have
access to both Python and R,
and your packages
will need to deal
with the relevant dependencies.
From personal
experience, reticulate
is a lot more explicit about how
it handles Python environments,
whereas with rpy2, you
need to do a little bit more
of the work yourself.
Now another issue is
object conversion.
Sometimes to work with
cross-language wrappers,
you need to handle
the conversion
of an object from one
language to another,
like you saw with rpy2.
And a third issue
are error messages.
Sometimes when an error
occurs in the language that
is being wrapped,
the error message
doesn't come through
in its entirety, which
can frustrate your efforts
to create nice, helpful error
messages.
But with all this being
said, cross-language wrappers
are a really useful tool
in your internal toolkit.
They can deal with
issues of missing
functionality or inconsistent
outputs between languages.
And there we have it,
three different ways
to build bilingual tools without
having to design two entirely
different solutions.
The goal of each
of these ideas is
to make the development process
and the maintenance process
much easier for you.
If you're an internal
tool developer working
in a bilingual
organization, I would
encourage you to seek out
these programming concepts
and ideas that can help to
bridge the gap between Python
and R. Ultimately
the goal of this
is to make your life as a
developer much, much easier.
Thank you for listening
and happy developing.